liver King how long have you been using
steroids
since I was 40. and how old are you now
44. so for the last four years you've
been using steroids and at age 40 how
massive were you at that point
I'd probably weighed 180 and you're what
now 195.
all right so you've come clean you feel
good truth shall set you free right
everything that Pat's dad said Gabriel's
signatures right there his wisest man I
know uh
do you think you'll still continue to
use steroids you know I believe so
deeply in this message that um I'm not
going to do it anymore
but why it feels like and hear me out
you did it you enjoyed doing it clearly
because I mean it made you feel better
it helped you with your self-esteem you
look better you know all the the
positives that came with steroids you've
admitted it
why don't you say yeah I've been using
steroids I'm sorry I lied to you guys
but if you use steroids now you think
that would ruin your entire message why
not just continue if you enjoy it that's
my question yeah well like I said I I
believe so deeply in this message and
that my root cause is really the
overtraining issue I got to figure that
out I got to figure out the over
training issue I gotta figure out the
self-worth issue
um but I do believe I can come off of
steroids
um I'm on testosterone and growth
hormone okay right and I'm on 0.6 CC's I
don't know if you know what that means
not a lot it's it's and so some of the
guys I've talked to they're like
I don't know what that's doing for you
actually
um I have no doubt that the growth
hormone has helped significantly how
addictive are steroids like I have
friends that look they've been partying
they got they got alcohol issues there's
people with you know drug issues pill
popping heroin you hear these crazy
stories about it's hard for me to get
off cigarette smokers all the above are
steroids addictive how addictive are
they I don't know I I've not come off
you know so
um I've not come off of testosterone
it's been a low dose of testosterone for
this amount of time
um I've been on growth hormone for a
year and a couple of months and so you
know in terms of the addiction you know
I don't know
um so what I'm going to do you know this
whole thing was an experiment you know
to go on it I found a pretty profound
difference in it and so now it's my time
to see okay what the [ __ ] can I do not
taking them at all and hopefully be able
to share that story
that's gonna be a dope Journey just
showing everybody because all the you
know the heart and soil I'm I'm you know
I'm saying a huge fan I use it I even
told Pat earlier I have grass-fed grass
finished Frozen liver I eat that almost
every day just not not too much but like
a couple ounces and just you know the
brain and everything I think it's going
to be a it'd be a cool transformation to
show everybody and bring everybody to
that Journey because like Pat said you
mess up everybody has Secrets he has
them he has them everybody in this
building has them I have them some worse
than others but that weight is off and I
think you know taking advantage of this
movement now because those fans that
were hurt now could say Okay manned up
and now let's see where this where this
Journey's gonna go I think I think it's
a it's going to be a good one because I
mean you're still you're still going to
keep working out you're still going to
do everything else so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetaining it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he about three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]